because it's important to listen to
everyone as many people you can and get
their input tsch graduates you made it
and if you can't please everybody all
the time or you part of the time I just
try my I try to do my best of doing the
right thing if you will not always if
you don't go you'll never know you have
to have that sometimes you need that
from an outside source in order to
stimulate you and get you inspired
almost a revved up about doing something
different
he's an American actor and producer who
has starred in over a hundred films here
and an Academy Award for portraying Jake
LaMotta in the 1980 film Raging Bull his
business ventures include co-founding
the film studio tribeca productions as
well as a Tribeca Film Festival he's
Robert DeNiro and here is my take on his
top ten rules for success rule number
three is my personal favorite I make
sure to stick around all the way to the
end for some special bonus clips and I I
mean personally I always try to listen
because I might be not and maybe I'm not
getting something I always try and take
everybody's because it's important to
listen to everyone as many people as you
can and get their input but then finally
you have to make your own decision about
what you're going to do and that's it
that's what you feel and that's it and
that that's the most important thing I
think the most important thing because
that's where the uniqueness comes in
because it's you you've done it it's
your thing it's not anybody else's it's
your choice and when young actors come
to you looking for advice what do you
tell I tell them just to keep at it and
not be you know discouraged body if
you're going first at your readings and
stuff like that you have to try you
always try your best and not really just
follow your instincts more than so you
can be free and easy about as opposed to
assume that you're not going to get it
so you have a more of a devil-may-care
attitude about I think that helps a lot
thank you for inviting me to celebrate
with you today Tisch graduates you made
it
and
think about that the graduates from the
College of Nursing they all have jobs
the graduates from the College of
Dentistry fully employed the Leonard and
Stern School of Business graduates
they're covered the School of Medicine
graduates each one will get a job the
proud graduates of the NY School of Law
they're covered and if they're not who
cares they're lawyers the English majors
are not a factor
they'll be home writing their novels
teachers there all be working jobs lousy
pay yeah but still working the graduates
in accounting they all have jobs
where does that leave you envious of
those accountants I doubt it
they had a choice maybe they were
passionate about accounting but I think
it's more likely that they used reason
and logic and common sense to reach for
a career that could give them the
expectation of success and stability
reason logic common sense at the Tisch
School of Arts are you kidding me but
you didn't have that choice did you you
discovered a talent developed an
ambition and recognized your passion
when you feel that you can't fight it
you just go with it when it comes to the
arts passion should always trump common
sense you want just following dreams
you're reaching for your destiny you're
a dancer a singer a choreographer
musician a filmmaker a writer a
photographer a director a producer and
actor an artist
yeah you
the good news is that that's not a bad
place to start now that you've made your
choice or rather succumb to it your path
is clear not easy but clear you have to
keep working it's that simple
how did you get into entrepreneurship
was it something that when you were
young you got inspired about it or
because I know your father was an artist
and your mother as well yeah I don't
know I think I mean I've always been
wanting to act or direct and but then
these opportunities came along and I
felt let's just take advantage of them
like no boon when I saw no I went to
Nobu years ago
over 20 years ago on 25 years ago and I
said if you ever want to open I went to
Matsuhisa his first restaurants if you
ever want to open a restaurant I was
there one time I said and I but many
times after but said everyone open a
restaurant in New York just let me know
you know because it was to me was a
no-brainer and he set the bar for a
crazy father-in-law alongside Ben
Stiller and the Focker clan all right
now look father I'm a patient man
that's what 19 months in a Vietnamese
prison camp will do to you but I will be
watching you studying your every move
well they were a commercial success
some critics lamented that first boys a
trivial role bring you beneath an actor
of his stature that's fine they can
criticize whatever and they could be
right I want to do those things you
can't please everybody all the time or
view part of the time are you a good
picture of scripts and things that you
do you get somebody else to help you
well I you get people to help you in
terms of getting feedback I have people
like my agent or people who work with me
they will read it and read a script and
tell me if they think it's well if it's
good and because I'm so busy I don't
have time to read everything that comes
along and sometimes it's just something
that I can see in a script that maybe no
one else can
and I follow my own instincts about it
why at this stage did you decide to
direct a picture was it because the
particular subject natural because you'd
had a yearning to direct uh well I was
wanted to direct oh yeah we have it was
since I was in my late teens early 20s
and I just never got around to it I
finally started realizing as I was
getting older by you know my early 40s
that I better really do it it's either
now or I'm never going to do it what is
the one thing that you want people to
think or to know about you I don't know
whatever I'm you know I'll try my best I
don't give a damn don't give a damn
about I care but I don't know what this
door I just try my I try to do my best
at doing the right thing if you will
then are always but so I hope I'll
proceed as that or appreciate it for
that it's difficult for me to come up
with advice for you who have already
said upon your life's work but I can
tell you some of the things I tell my
own children for first whatever you do
don't go to Tisch School of the Arts get
an accounting degree instead then I
contradict myself and as corny as it
sounds I tell them don't be afraid to
fail I urge them to take chances to keep
an open mind to welcome new experiences
and new ideas
I tell them them I tell them that if you
don't go you'll never know you have to
have them just to have to be bold and go
out there and take your chances what I
like is if somebody says I never thought
of you for this type of part but then I
but then I thought yeah you would be
good for just for that very reason and
it would spark something in me that
makes it different you know you and I
were even talking a little bit about
that mentioning some things that that
sometimes you need that from an outside
source in order to stimulate you and get
you inspired almost a revved up about
doing something different
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this beauty because Jurgen 803
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I'd also love to
know which of Robert De Niro's top ten
rules had the biggest impact on you and
why leave it in the comments and I will
join in the discussion thank you so much
for watching you too believe and I'll
see you soon
do you remember the audition when you
first met an arrow that was yeah I mean
that was one of those incredible
auditions that came around that I
suppose every kid had been waiting for
for a long period of time because it's
just not that often that you get a
starring role above Robert De Niro and
this incredible you know screenplay and
was you know Ellen Barkin and Michael
Kate Jones and was just everyone was
sort of feeding for this role and I got
down I suppose to the final five and
there was like a last sort of day
Toby was there and I I do remember
thinking to myself I got to do something
I got to do something to stand out and
in the audition there was art lence and
Michael Keaton Jones Arlington was the
producer and DeNiro and I remember there
was a mustard jar scene and he had to
jam a mustard jar in my eye repeatedly
it was an abuse scene and the script so
didn't call for it but I got up and I he
said now is it empty is it empty and I
got up and I screamed ah like completely
unnecessary but I screamed in his face
and i sat there you know with my head
you know looking like a red tomato and
and and everyone started laughing at me
and then the entire room deniro
everybody was in hysterics i sat there
frozen's thinking oh my god I just
screwed this entire office maybe got and
I just sat there frozen and then you
know Bob and traditional DeNiro fashion
kind of just look at me when it's good
and and and then you know we carried on
doing the scene and I think I actually
had dinner with DeNiro recently and he
told me no I was the one who said I was
the one who said you should get the get
the job
that's n u s-- are you coming he'll I'm
standing here you make a move you make
the move Jim move
you talking to me you talking to me
talking to me
well who the hell are you talking to
talking to me
well I'm the only one here look do you
think you're talking oh yeah okay huh
listen you've you screwheads
here's a man who would not take it
anymore
a man who stood up against the scum the
[ __ ] the dog's the filth here is
someone who stood up here is
is dead